[Music]
if you're thinking about
joining the david pacman show
he's got a lot of content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the subject
[Music]
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about
his gardens pretty good garden now but
it's not for everyone
you should also know
that there is a bonus show
producer pat will give his take which is
a pretty
decent perspective pat knows what he's
talking about
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to
add his name at the end of the subject
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the search criteria moment
of the sexual experience would ask the
young lady who's your daddy
this should be remixed if officer akimov
is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here
uh that's beautiful
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
a long-legged mcdaddy is the most
successful
pimp on planet earth to reverence the
word of god
to trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons
of lies what happened in prison that
brought you to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
bush singer and george bush junior have
been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
[Music]
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of lives
everything you're doing is wrong
it's amazing
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman he is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about i don't know being a beta
male
and being an alpha male what are we
talking about here
i'm sorry i think you're doing very
there are males like most men today
yeah male 1 they think and act like a
woman they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot hang on agree
with everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
[Music]
[Music]
pacman he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like you're asking bizarre questions
you're actually
like you're hearing it and you're
wasting my time i appreciate that
all right goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
all men who are progressive
are we
all right welcome everybody what a day
um it's great to have like a catch-up
day
that i i just had a bunch of stuff to go
through but we actually have a bunch of
news to talk about as well
um i'm back in the studio it's been
great uh to be on the road but it's
great to be back
it's all great i guess is the way that i
would say it we've got voicemails we
have unban requests we have news we have
um some important announcements and i
will take phone calls today i have been
unable to for a little bit but i will
take phone calls today
if we get to our hundred member goal we
will get the discord lines wide open
and um it's gonna be uh it's gonna be
something else it's gonna be something
else so
where to even start um let's start with
the big news
the uh the haitian president has been
assassinated in his home
um this is uh an insane
story um this is from the associated
press and port-au-prince
a squad of gunmen assassinated haitian
president joe van el and
wounded his wife in an overnight raid on
their home
wednesday inflicting more chaos in the
caribbean country that was already
enduring gang violence
soaring inflation and protests of his
increasingly authoritarian rule
interim prime minister claude josef
who confirmed the killing said the
police and military were in control of
security in haiti
the poorest country in the americans
were a history of dictatorship and
political upheaval
have long stymied the consolidation of
democratic rule
in an interview with the ap joseph
called for an international
investigation into the assassination
said the elections scheduled for later
this year should be held
and pledged to work with moz's allies
and opponents alike
quote we need every single one to move
the country forward he alluded to
enemies of the president describing him
as a man of courage
who would oppose some oligarchs in the
country and we believe those things are
not without consequences
there was confusion about who should
take control and widespread anxiety
among haitians
authorities declared a state of siege
and closed the international airport
the normally bustling streets of the
capital port-au-prince were empty and
quiet
sporadic gunshots were heard in the
distance
um now so so a couple of important
details that i want to
uh go over here um
boat [ __ ] edmund the haitian ambassador
to the u.s said the attack
on the 53 year old was carried out by
foreign mercenaries and professional
killers well orchestrated
and that they were masquerading as
agents of the usda
the dea has an office in port-au-prince
to help encounter narcotics so listen
it's so early we don't know what's going
on yet
okay but very quickly that has been
taken by
some to mean the dea actually did it
there's no evidence of that right now
now i'm i'm not an idiot
in the sense of do american agencies
sometimes get involved in
in central uh caribbean and latin
america yeah of course
there's no evidence of that at this
point in time i have no interest in
convincing anyone one way or the other
because
all i know right now is there's no
evidence of that they appear to have
been
masquerading as dea that's number one uh
number two
haiti has asked the u.s government for
assistance with the investigation
adding assassins could have escaped over
the land border to the dominican
republic or by sea
that also is is worrying many people
into saying
uh oh this this is a pretense to get the
u.s
involved and you know um no reason to
think that that's the case right now the
story is absolutely insane and the
volatility in haiti expected to to
continue
now going from the associated press to
the new york post so always you know new
york post
okay take it take it with a grain of
salt um there were a couple details here
that i wanted to add um
ah okay language an unidentified group
of individuals
some of whom were speaking in spanish
attacked the private residence of the
president of the republic and mortally
wounded him
um okay you know they they speak french
and creole
in haiti certainly spanish is spoken in
the dominican republic which which
shares the physical island with haiti
i just don't think we could you know
everybody's reading into that with a hot
take
already this is just very very early i
don't think we can read anything
into that and then again going to even
less reliable news sources
the u.s son is saying the u.s
could send troops into haiti now who do
they claim to be quoting here
man um my ad blocker just can do nothing
about this
who is the quote um
professor oh it's a professor okay yeah
so it's just a random professor says
it's conceivable that troops will be
sent into haiti
this is why you have to be really
careful with this stuff the sun went
and found some professor willing to say
it's possible the u.s will send troops
in
at this point again until we actually
see that um
i i don't believe that that is the case
uh and of course at any time haiti could
ask for help in some way so
an insane situation in haiti
the president has been assassinated in
his home
um incredible and there's actually a
very
i mean it's sort of a sad history well
our super chats seem to be a little bit
big here let me see if i can shrink that
a little
um there we go there's uh
jared wait no that's not where we want
to go jared diamond has actually written
quite a bit
about haiti and um
the dominican republic and there's this
super racist interpretation of why the
dr
is so much better off than haiti i'm
sure you can imagine what it is
haiti has the black people whereas the
dominican republic has hispanic people
and more people of european origin
that's the
that's the racist hot take about haiti
and the dominican republic
the reality is that uh due to what was
known
yeah i know people are saying that's
yeah that's not my view okay to be very
clear
that's the view of uh of of some racists
first of all
it's not like the dominican republic's
doing great but they are doing
significantly better than haiti
it actually has a lot to do with the
geography
and jared diamond explains this
beautifully in uh in
in his book collapse i believe is the
one where he writes about this
um early and rapid deforestation
done on the haitian side and not on the
dominican side
combined with some significant
differences about
uh prevailing winds and weather
and elevation and a whole bunch of other
things explain
a lot of the difference in circumstances
between the dominican republic and haiti
that's a topic for a different day
topic for a different day but no
shortage of disgusting racism when it
comes to
almost anything in this case um
the differences between haiti and the
dominican republic
uh one super chat came in uh do
left media profit from things not
getting better
listen uh the the the media in general
uh only is profitable
when there is interest in what's taking
place in the world
one can argue if it leads it bleeds and
this type of thing i mean no one media
outlet
really has any say or control over that
so
you know i mean when there's more things
going on more people watch the news
that's kind of an undeniable
undeniable reality okay let's get where
do we want to go next do we want to do
trump suing everybody trump did this
press conference it was completely
whacked out
we can we can go through that um
let's see what else is going on we are
looking at this
tropical storm elsa i don't think it's
expected to be
that big of a deal so i don't know yeah
expect it to be
become a tropical depression i don't
know that we really need to do too much
weather stuff here
um unless we really had sort of like a a
bona fide
emergency situation a couple of things i
do want to mention though
number one we youtube has just rolled
out a new feature
called subscriber only chat now this is
very different than subscriber only chat
on twitch on twitch subscriber only chat
means
only people who pay can chat we don't
turn that on
typically youtube subscriber just means
you're a free subscriber you just hit
the subscribe button and that's it
we've enabled it it's not member only
chat it's subscriber only chat there's
two
two reasons one we're getting more and
more complaints
about uh right it's like follower only
chat on twitch
we're getting more and more complaints
about the toxicity of the chat
on uh youtube that's number one
and then number two i'm actually curious
how many of our youtube viewers
aren't subscribers um because if we're
getting a lot of youtube viewers that
are not subscribers that's an
opportunity okay so we have
subscriber only chat turned on on
youtube
i will report back to you and tell you
whether uh it makes any kind of uh
difference
or whatever okay robert brunswick says
via super chat hi david love you brother
love to all my fellow packers
whoa ryan says if there were a rep who
was left-wing but governed like
mcconnell in terms of procedures and
obstruction would that be impactful or
short-lived it would be impactful
uh we we actually on the friday show
we're actually going to talk a little
bit about
um part of the reason why uh blowing up
the filibuster could backfire on
democrats
is democratic incompetence i'll have
more about that on friday
the unintelligence says david's the man
two in chat if you are packing right now
i don't even know what that means that
could mean a number of different things
and we're not even going to get into
that
all right um before we go on to the next
thing i do want to thank people who have
um
supported so far bunch of people dumping
in memberships
over on twitch it is let's see here
wilita hc has signed up big massive
dumps
red bone 76 is a new member power laces
manno drizzle dumps um
cosmos 84 as well as word
fencer they call them dumps uh hug
fetish and master mcclevy
also milo wild kicking us off
at nine right away we will open phone
lines
at 100 today and you can also use the
coupon code
indictment 21 indictment 21
to sign up on my website okay let me get
to some unban requests before we get to
the
um trump stuff which we're going to look
at next
i do have the gavel back in action three
different
unban requests to look at a user who
goes by the name
big papa grundle oh god
um showed up and said
tanks then david pakman looks like sam
cedar then sent
about 20 different emotes
then just typed juche gang about a
hundred times in a wall of text
and then they were banned they then
requested an
unban help my account got hacked i can't
stop
jooshie gang another hundred times so
that is deny
and confirm that is a perma-ban
next user goes by the name the kitty the
kid dungeon master that's already
just the username is already probably
not so great
they showed up and they said hi where
are you question
hello j j b
j b what the f is wrong with you pacman
what the hell is wrong with you pacman
david pakman david pakman fu they were
banned
they submitted an unban request
which just links me to a twitter profile
that is a permaban
and then lastly a user named test
and oh oh boy who says i believe the
mark of the beast will happen
something will happen i do not
understand why you show this and do not
agree with nothing oh this was during
the trump rally
i love trump trump 2024 trump will win
2024 all back-to-back in all caps
they were banned their unban request is
clean democracy uh it's borderline
but it is going to be a perma-ban
all right so that's that as far from the
standpoint
of unban requests okay
number two request for help if anybody
in the audience is really good with obs
and stream labs obs i could use some
help we've recently gotten some new
hardware
i'm really trying to figure out should i
be using
software encoding for these streams
should i be using the nvidia
encoder can i set a different bit rate
for streaming versus recording because
that's sort of like a key thing
if not should i be using stream labs for
the streams and regular obs for
recording
um what other questions i need the nerds
to rise up
and get in touch with me just a ton of
different things a ton of different
things
um so it would be really great if
anybody is
very good with obs if you could
um if you could get in touch with me
info
davidpakman.com all right so there is
that
let's get directly into this trump oh oh
hold on sorry i do have some new
elements in my sound board let me tell
you the new things that i have
i have a couple new trump things like
for example
um i've got this one
if ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
i'd be dating her i've got that someone
sent me that
oh hold on what's going on here there we
go this one
i'm a very stable genius and i think i
added one more
we're no this one we had and then we
fell in love
okay yeah okay so i've i added those
i also got a couple of other biden ones
give me a break with all due respect
that's a bunch of malarkey
that's a bunch of malarkey this idea is
a bunch of malarkey
so a couple new biden elements
um we've expanded the bernie sanders we
used to only have this
yeah good okay we've also now added
i wrote the damn bill and i wish it was
better quality but that's not bad
i wrote the damn bill and then one other
you're wrong
okay so we've got a couple bernie
elements and then i also now have a
jessie lee peterson sound board
it's amazing
better girl better now you love me
she hug up everything you're doing is
wrong
okay so we've got those what i do need
right now though is if someone can send
me trump
doing the bleach injections and then
also
convalescent plasma i all the very i
need really high quality clean drops of
a bunch of the times trump said
convalescent plasma that would be really
useful so
we're continuing to build up the uh
sound board okay
let's get into this trump event donald
trump today
announced he is suing class action
twitter and facebook why because they
banned him and
trump doesn't understand the first
amendment among other things
and trump is suing everybody
and let's just go through some of these
clips and see what this was all about it
was
humiliating dude i'm filing as
the lead class representative a major
class action lawsuit against
the big tech giants including facebook
google and twitter
whoa what just happened that was bizarre
uh okay so trump's suing facebook google
and twitter
uh where was that one okay there it is
all right so trump is is filing a
lawsuit okay
next trump clearly not understanding the
first amendment
the founding fathers so if you're suing
twitter and facebook and you're talking
about the founding fathers
it's probably already off the rails
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers okay let's continue
describe this right in the very first
amendment to our constitution because
they knew that free speech
is essential to the prevention
and look to the prevention of hara
hara hara that's h-a-h-r-r-a-h
ha-ra um i think he's sort of glitched
there
to be perfectly frank um
it that seemed like he got confused with
himself
um but this is a very very strange clip
i think i need to see this one one more
time the founding fathers
inscribed this right in the very first
amendment to our constitution because
they knew
that free speech is essential to the
prevention and look to the prevention of
horror and to the preservation of our
republic oh man and god bless
the united states so none of this has
anything to do with the first amendment
okay the government is not limiting
trump's ability to speak or anything
like that
um so that's just absurd
now this clip i don't even know that i
fully understand let's look at it
a lot of people ask me uh about dr fauci
i like dr fought you actually get along
with him great but they said why didn't
you fire him i said no he was good
he'd recommend something i'd do the
opposite and we always turned out to be
around
this is an event about trump suing i
guess to get what he misunderstands to
be his first amendment rights back
and somehow he's attacking fauci
um fox news actually cut away
hilariously
um fox went to something about covet
origins
whereas newsmax stuck with it
um it's it's all really really weird
the event continued and trump took
questions this one i don't even get like
tell me if you can understand what on
earth trump is talking about in this one
just just to clarify um who should be
the arbiter of
what's hate what's offensive what should
not be
uh published what goes beyond free
speech and because so much of this
your banning has to do with comments you
made around january 6th
just to clarify further what did you do
to
stop the insurrection as some people
call it and
why were you not able to stop it so that
whole
event unfortunate event just went
through congress and a report was issued
and my name wasn't even mentioned
and i appreciate that i was surprised
frankly because
they would have come up with their
typically biased at least on the
democrat side statement
the report came out as you saw two weeks
ago my name wasn't even mentioned that
was an
unfortunate event i say though guys the
insurrection was unfortunate
it was unfortunate that's it where
people are being treated unbelievably
unfairly when you look at people in
prison
and nothing happens to antifa
and they burned down cities and killed
people i i should have assumed it was
going to end up
being about antifa there were no guns in
the capitol
they burned except for the gun that shot
ashley babbitt
that appears to be a complete and total
lie and nobody knows who that men were
if that were the opposite way that man
would be
all over he would be the the most
well-known and i believe
i can say man because i believe i know
exactly who it is
trump's desperate by the way to out that
officer
big supporter of law enforcement but
desperate to out that that officer
but he would be the most well-known
person
in this country in the world but the
person that shot ashley babbitt
boom right through the head just boom
there was no reason for that
trump's mad about police brutality now
so-called
and why isn't that person being opened
up and why isn't that being said they
gotta open them up
do an autopsy well they're alive but
open them up
they've already written it off they said
that case is closed
if that were the opposite that case
would be going on for years and years
and it would not be pretty so i just
thought this was a very important time
yeah please so what was the answer the
question was about trump being banned
from twitter for the things he said on
january 6th
and he talked about antifa
really really weird and then here is
trump
with his new mantra
if you say it long enough hard enough
often enough
and wide enough as well people will
start to believe it
that's what happened with russia that's
what happened with ukraine that's what
happened with
well the worst is when they don't say it
like
the laptop from hell yeah they call them
dumps yeah so there it is
trump suing uh everyone i guess
and uh class action lawsuit i don't
think it's really going to go anywhere
but we will we will have to wait and see
i do want to say thank you to big easy
as well as weatherman
nix faros and twisted hawk
all of whom just signed up as well as
sam the sleazebag
via twitch putting us at 14. we will
open phone lines today my friends if we
get to 100
website members and twitch subs i would
encourage you right now we
i may even do uh i'll do one trump drop
for each website membership
sign up at jointpakman.com let's open
those phone lines
let's uh let's keep dumping in audio
drops and you can use the coupon code
indictment 21
celebrating the 15 felony count
indictment against trump's against
trump's cfo on our website it's an
amazing and beautiful thing
all right and i'll we'll thank everybody
and hopefully open up some phone lines
let me go to some of the super chats
that are
continuing to pour in here
uh where did i leave off will trump have
to give
a deposition in his facebook twitter
lawsuit he will be asked about 1-6 so it
will never happen it's a grift for money
yes you're probably you're almost
certainly right if
d philip buster stops the voter
suppression
by the reps won't it mean that the reps
not win again
and thus don't we don't have to worry
that the lack of filibuster
will be used against dems help me
understand
help me understand i i don't know what
you mean what currency is that
sgd currency
uh singapore dollars okay yeah i
apologize i'm not totally understanding
the the question
but i love it and i so appreciate uh
your support today
giving you my five bucks instead of
donating to trump's new lawsuit grift
thanks bae photo
how serious do you think democrats are
taking 22 and 24 because here in
northeastern pennsylvania there is no
shortage of trump bs still up
the cult is still very much intact they
seem to have missed linking january 6 to
republicans and letting the
letting the gut voting rights yeah i'm
i'm actually
extraordinarily worried about 24 and 22
i put a segment on yesterday's show
about this
and um i think if 24 is a rematch of six
of 20
i think it's very bad actually for
democrats very very bad
jacob ratner asks sir
mr president is it reasonable to call
trumpism neo-fascism yeah to some degree
in some loose sense sure
sure ronnie cortex says david you're
great and smart guy
love your show from brazil where we
still have a tropical trump the stupid
bolsonaro
also known as bozo yeah i don't envy
that at all
daniel says is who shot ashley babbitt
the sequel
to who framed roger rabbit it may well
be
it may well be big shout out to lizzy
haller sir you're on the cover of time
magazine again
lizzy just signed up at joinpackman.com
and his new
member number 15 today we will open the
phones
at 100. um few other
super chats trump staying in the
spotlight will hurt his 24 chances it
will activate the democratic base
i know that there are people who are
emailing me that and insisting on that
part of why the democratic
base was activated on uh in 2020
is because trump was president trump
not being in the oval office will mean
that a trump 24 campaign
is not going to activate as many
democrats as it did in 2020
unfortunately voters have a
uh a short memory and um
i i am very worried about that i think
that that's a that's a complacent
uh perspective okay
let's see what else please do another
event oh hold on
david please update assange case the
government case is dissolving he doesn't
deserve to rot in prison
all right please do another event with
jesse lee peterson
maybe maybe someday donald j trump if
joe wins you'll never see me again he
lied yeah that was a lie
that was a big lie watch the new york
times january 6 video yesterday can't
help but feel outraged we must not
forget january 6th we need to show up
for midterms
left is best yeah i'm i'm very worried
about lack of enthusiasm in
uh in 2022 and 2024.
very very worried okay um
let's see do p what do people want next
do you want me to go through
some voicemails or do you want me to
take
my artistic preferences test and see if
i am correct in believing
that uh avant garde and contemporary art
are my preferred styles what do people
want
oh boy end the stream okay all right
very good
let's do it no just kidding i'm here
um okay yeah let me let me do the art
thing real quick just and then and then
we'll get i think that this might be
interesting this is the artistic
preferences scale this is super easy
you just look at paintings and you say
which ones you like more okay
let's let's see where i come out on this
here we go
which work of art is better for me
the the i strongly prefer the one on the
left very easy
which work of art is better
i think i prefer the one on the left but
not quite as strongly
which work of art is better
slightly the one on the left
definitely the left oh okay this is
tougher now
this is tougher now
i'm gonna go with slightly the one on
the right
definitely the one on the right easy
hmm
kind of indifferent here
neither of these really speaks to me
i'll go with neither
um huh
think i prefer the one on the right
prefer the right not not strongly so
huh
there's some actually which which one
speaks to me more
kind of neither kind of indifferent here
um also indifferent here yeah
i don't know definitely the right on
this one
absolutely the right on this one
these are tougher first of all they're
so different that it's hard to even
really compare
so i think i'm gonna go with neither
i think i actually prefer the left on
this one
i prefer the right prefer the right
the one on the left is like the weird
type of stuff i like yeah so definitely
left
um definitely left
definitely left
left but not so strongly
definitely left
prefer the right
the dog i like i like the inclusion of
the dog
i'm gonna go with neither oh love the
one on the right that's exactly up my
up my alley um
prefer the right definitely right
right but not by as much
left right
oof this one is tough just neither i
guess
left slightly okay did you try your best
and can we store your data and see how
they did that did you try your best
and can we store the data sure store my
data
um do i want to answer four to eight
minutes of additional questions no i
don't
okay abstract
and painterly stylistic preferences
abstract linear whoa
linear versus painterly realistic versus
abstract okay yeah i think that this
makes sense
um content preferences i have a slight
preference for masculine content
whoa there's a lot of people who are not
necessarily going to like that
yeah that's going to be a disappointment
to some of the people in my circles
um score explanation
your score for linear versus painterly
was 12.
you have a strong preference for
painterly works
where the brush strokes are visible in
contrast with linear works where shapes
are bounded by lines and the goal
is a photorealistic depiction
interesting your score for realistic
versus abstract was 13. you have a
strong preference for abstract works
and your score for masculine versus
feminine
is -4 you have a moderate preference
for work of works of art that depicts
subjects stereotypically
of interest to males like fighting
machines ships and architecture
as opposed to subjects stereotypically
associated with
females like women in dresses
that is an interesting set of results
all right
so i did it this is on the website
openpsychometrics.org
if people are uh looking for that
okay good so we've gotten that out of
the way i do want to say thank you to
robot mugabe for signing up via twitch
prime
always appreciate that also a massive
massive thank you i couldn't i couldn't
thank you enough
um pavinder for signing up with the
coupon code
better21 big massive dumps and then also
paddy hasselbring patty hasselbring
signing up with the coupon code better21
very much appreciate that
sir sure all right number 17
and 18 the coupon code indictment 21 is
actually my favorite
okay use that one i i suggest let's look
at a couple of other super chats then
we're going to get into voicemails
let me see where i left off
um thoughts on what happened over the
weekend in massachusetts with the rise
of the moors is that the thing with
state police
rise of the moors yeah yeah we covered
that on today's bonus show it's insane i
didn't even realize that was the name of
the group
i thought it was just like sovereign
citizen nuttery it's uh
full full analysis on today's bonus show
um imagine if trump was sentenced to 50
life sentences and 600 years in federal
prison by a judge who has
an intense hatred for trump yeah it's
just not going to happen
uh oh here let's listen to the uh we've
got some analysis here of this uh
bogus trump lawsuit a suit in order and
speaking of suits nice jacket my friend
thank you so much i really appreciate
that breaking out the uh the obama tan
suit for uh for the summertime i love it
in order to win these lawsuits donald
trump is basically making the argument
uh that his first amendment rights have
been violated by these
tech companies now for those of you
familiar with the first amendment
yeah it says that congress shall make no
law uh abridging the freedom of speech
and
uh you know the exercise of religion uh
publishing etc
so ultimately what he's saying is that
these companies are effectively arms of
the federal government he wants
uh the judiciary to basically agree with
them that they are arms the federal
government and therefore
um can be uh punished for having uh
violated his constitutional rights the
lawyers that i've spoken to today
uh and some of those that i've seen in
the public space say this is
essentially a ridiculous idea and that
the courts will laugh it out
uh but i do think that we we can hear
from president trump former president
trump himself
i think we got a snippet of him today
we're demanding an end to the shadow
banning
stop to the silencing and a stop to
the blacklisting banishing and canceling
that you know so well
oh my god our case will prove this
censorship is unlawful it's
unconstitutional and it's completely
unamerican
stand back and stand by and so allison
as you hear the president uh
saying those things um you know he
obviously has got an opportunity to try
to prove it in court
most folks think that most lawyers think
that this will be dismissed he uh
he has some sort of uh you know perilous
treacherous
uh things are waiting for awaiting him
if these suits actually go forward
yeah in terms of depositions that he
might give discovery that he might have
to do
uh around the january six riots and
other events that led
uh twitter and the other platforms to
suspend his account
can you imagine all right so i have a
couple questions here first john why a
class action suit and why not go it
alone it would seem to me that if the
president were acting just as the
president it might have more power than
bringing all these other people
in here is there a strategy here that
i'm missing
i mean surprisingly i think it's the
exact opposite in that
um what he's trying to do is show that
these companies are powerful
and that he is simply a representative
of a larger class of powerless there you
go
and that these his argument is that
these couples are like i said
effectively an arm of the government
acting against the individual citizens
and in order to paint himself
anchor seems anxious to move on to the
next question action
so however he he painted it sounds like
from what
what you've said it doesn't look like
it's gonna go anywhere but does that
even matter
does this have value to him just for the
attention it brings and the attention he
gets
as he tries to either fundraise run for
office again himself or just
draw some attention to the republican
party it absolutely has value to him
number one
if you go to the washington post website
the wall street journal website most of
the major news websites
this is on there today uh you know this
was picked up by
uh most media outlets whether they're
print or uh television or otherwise
so he gets that but also he does a
fundraising appeal off of this and he
tries to convince
others that he is representative of a
class of of of beleaguered
uh conservatives what he says is a
silent majority that's being
um you know abused by these tech
companies that he says right
what a poor guy of course uh what he
doesn't point out is that when twitter
suspended his account
uh in january of 2021 he was still the
sitting president of the united states
uh he was in fact the most identifiable
identifiable and powerful state actor
and arguably most privileged yes sort of
separates you a little bit from
everybody else in that class action
suit uh john i imagine that they are not
commenting because it's a legal issue
but i'd be remiss if i didn't ask
anything from the big three on this yet
yeah our colleague dylan byers reached
out to both facebook and twitter and
both of them were declining to comment
i think you're probably right about the
strategy behind that there's not
uh really a need for them to do that at
this point and uh
and any anything they say could be
potentially in conflict with their legal
strategy
yeah all right well it's a class-action
suit that doesn't look like it's going
very far but it got us
john allen in the first block of our 5
p.m show in a
uh barack obama style uh tan suit jacket
and what else says summer besides all
right so yeah it's going nowhere it's
going absolutely and completely nowhere
big thank you to kyle kludash
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code
indictment 21. oh no sam
cedar also want to say thank you to phil
box
as well as louis curtin for signing up
via twitch that is 19
20 and 21. let me get to a couple of
other super chats and then we're going
to get into the voicemails
you say biden is in trouble in 24 but
you also said it's hard to unseat an
incumbent president why the change no
change
as a general principle it's difficult to
unseat incumbent presidents
trump was unseated um as a general
principle
it's hard to unseat incumbent presidents
but the particulars
of trump versus 82 year old joe biden
or a kamala harris with a low approval
rating which is what she's suffering
from
right now uh strikes me as potentially
problematic it's just
we've got to think beyond just any one
idea
already clipped the art test and sent to
some artist friends all said they never
saw anything like it perfect score
yeah um in fact i got a call from
uh i got a text from my doctor who said
he has never seen anybody do what i was
able to do on that art test it's really
actually pretty shocking stuff
hey david any thoughts on gwar being on
fox news recently
it was the most watchable honest fox
news segment i've seen in years none at
all is
is that like a heavy metal band i think
gwar not super familiar with it
if the filibuster is eliminated won't
the democrats obviously win more votes
thus why do we care that the reps will
use it against the democrats
uh yeah it'll work for the next few
months
maybe um and then it could be completely
destructive to the country for the
following decade
um or whenever republicans take control
again it's a more complicated issue but
we've elaborated on it
because it is so important have you
heard about the bible study group that
the fbi busted
no i will check it out
fbi bible study
let's take a look at the oh this looks
insane
see what we've got here fbi
infiltrates group whose members wanted
to test homemade bombs
surveil the capital secede from the u.s
the fbi has infiltrated a quote bible
study
group in virginia that after the january
6 riot had members discussing
surveilling the u.s capitol
and their wish for secession from the
u.s investigators closely followed one
member's plans
to build and test molotov cocktails
according to unsealed documents
uh the startling new case landing six
months after the pro-trump insurrection
adds to the more than 500 capital riot
federal criminal cases already in court
fleshes out what's known about the
justice department's understanding of
the continued interests of right-wing
extremists
to allegedly interfere with the us
government and discuss with each other
how to do so
um the newly descr disclosed case
against virginia man
fi duong who also goes by
monkey king and jim arose after dwong
interacted with undercover law
enforcement several times on january 6th
and into recent months
when the fbi ultimately gained access to
his group in virginia then accompanied
him to an old jail
as dwong allegedly pursued bomb building
oh my god
sounds like they've got this guy dead to
rights law enforcement's undercover
interactions with duong and contacts are
laid out in a 14-page statement
yeah that's crazy i wouldn't be
surprised if defense lawyers
claim entrapment just because that's
what they like to do in these situations
but we will follow it and see where it
goes that that's crazy though
that is genuinely nuts get a load of
trump's faux
office of the president seal on the
podium truly pathetic yeah i
i like let me see if i can go back to it
um
yeah this is a biz it's the lectern
remember the podium i think is the
entire
thing like the little stage this is the
lectern you can't fully see it
but it's like a version of the
presidential seal that it's everything
about it it just
is so pathetic um it's
it's amazing okay
one other super chat it doesn't surprise
me trump is planning a class action suit
against big tech and cancellation
he's a power hungry sore loser who had
the biggest cancellation in 2020 when he
was not elected president well said
very much well said all right let's get
into some voicemails again
we're still catching up getting back
from the vacation
there are so many voicemails
and we're just going through them to
prove to you
that i'm not like picking i'm not
hiding all these really great voicemails
from you okay let's listen
hey david i'm one of the few that still
hasn't got vaccinated yet and uh
just uh had a little extra incentive
today i went out to get my hair cut and
i walked inside and i immediately turned
around so i forgot my mask
i walked out to my car to put it on and
somebody started tapping at the window
and i'm like well that can't be
they're not chatting for me are they and
so i walked back in with my mask on and
the guy
almost started screaming at me telling
me uh you know there's no need for an
ass nowhere we don't have any masks in
here anymore so
and i thought to myself okay well i
guess i better take it off because i
mean you know i want to get my hair cut
but uh
yeah just one more extra incentive to uh
for people like me that haven't
got vaccinated yet to you know go ahead
and just get one anyway
okay i love yourself i don't even know i
totally get that but if you're gonna go
ahead and get vaccinated
um that's uh that's a really great thing
okay hey david is it just me or is there
something kind of calmy about asking
people to stand at attention
and recite their pledge to
a pledge of allegiance to our state just
curious on your thoughts
i'm against the pledge of allegiance
yeah i find it i find it wacky
um all right let's listen to a couple
others
oh hi david um this is uh well i don't
even know if i'm supposed to identify
myself in such a situation where i might
be played on the show
but um okay i'll just let you know i
have an unusual first name that's why
i'm destined
to identify myself because someone might
know me
and okay all right well then we'll just
get off of it i mean i can see that it's
a full minute of explaining the name so
we're moving on hey david um
i'm i don't know if you're on your
journey you've reached your destination
it's a friday 8 49 pm eastern time
i don't have access to uh
um the internet right now so
um you know i heard you say a few live
streams ago not that long ago but um and
she had friends in miami
friends from argentina that were coming
to college jobs and when the
collapse of the um 12 floor condominium
and suicide there happened to be
two argentinians
okay let's uh let's continue
so um i thought this was really weird
because um i think also
england and slaves didn't do as well at
one point i'm not sure if i did that or
not but then
um when
[Music]
the british were talking about the
monarchy they were like they wanted to
like defy the monarchy and they didn't
like approve of the monarchy because
they were like we don't like being in
like a tough
position and you you guys jealousy out
of what i have to do every day
huh okay
hello david uh my name is mark i'm a
supporter
uh recently i heard a caller or somebody
made a
comment and text to you about uh
mentioned a book called the color of law
by richard rothstein
i think you would find it particularly
um
a good read all right so yeah people
recommended that book to me
oh yeah and also i noticed that england
was like influencing some of
the israeli people um saying that they
should take crazy
in order to get i see people in the chat
saying
i must have hand-picked these because
they're all wacky in their own way
i'm i'm just going through we're still
on june 25
okay that was our on june 26th i
streamed and i played a bunch of these
on july 3rd i streamed and i played a
bunch of these we're still
on the june 25 voicemails okay that was
our first day off
we're still on june 25th we're up to
june 25 at 9 00 pm that's as far as
we've gotten
okay go to the military and then they go
over to england and they get educated
he wasn't telling me very much i feel
like borderline tries to uh
kidnap me but um
i'm just like no no no um
but i i honestly don't know that much
about jewish people i just found out
recently that they might be involved
in the holocaust oh my god
okay same same caller calls back an hour
later
so the very first person that told me
that i looked like anybody
was an indian okay then they called back
a half hour later
but uh like jin and jackson is muslim
okay so now we're off that um
let's let's continue hi
david uh my name is neil
i watch you pretty regularly
i do enjoy your content most of the time
um i did have a
potential um
discussion um
about gun violence okay so this goes a
full three minutes and gets cut off and
they don't ever really get to the
question
i'm seeing transcripts as this goes i
can't do three minutes of that you know
with you guys
um oh god okay this might be the egg man
hi guys that stephen crowder guy that
wouldn't debate sam
cedar david pakman that man beats you
in life every single day you know why
he's having a baby right now he's making
a moronic
conservative baby and you and your
educated
liberal intellectual girlfriend slash
wife are not making a baby as far as i
know
that means that no matter what you do or
what he does he's gonna
continue his racist idiotic be
bullcrap way of thinking with another
child
and this is finally a strong voicemail
you're just gonna die with you
dave or hopefully maybe your brother
will have some kids but
dave don't you see the only way to win
this is to have
children and continue our life legacy i
know you're teaching people on the phone
you know you're teaching people on the
air
all over but the best way is have a
child because that baby is going to be a
little you
stephen crowder wins the debate in the
world against you
every day because he's having a baby
right now and you're not
that's important not 50 babies dave just
one
um i'm sorry i know he's too all right
okay so there's the egg man
oh no sam cedar then troy york called in
at 5 a.m
hi this is jamal jenkins from university
parks
uh illinois and i'm calling in response
to your video about
tucker carlson being the uh
right-wing propaganda the architect of
right-wing propaganda
architect architect i just want to say
that uh david pakman
is the architect of left-wing
propaganda all right so there's troy
york
again guys i'm i'm giving you guys
everything we're now up to june 26th at
5
47 a.m i do i'm gonna do my best to wear
this
uh correctly but uh donald trump you
know
is talking about a lot about 2022 and
his candidates
and uh you know how important it is that
that they win
in 2022 and take over the majority
um do you think joe biden will get
involved at any point and
say anything to
you know to to get people out into the
polls and stuff and
yeah so at least this is a specific
question i believe joe biden will get
involved in campaigning
for 2022 no question whatsoever
hi david um i wanted to ask when
engaging in a conversation
as a progressive i was wondering what
topics you think i would have the most
luck finding some common ground
with with us conservative when i have
conversations with someone as a
competing ideology
it's so often focused on the ways in
which we disagree
and i have a theory that if i was able
to focus the conversation
on the topics in which we do agree we
would have
much more of a productive conversation
yeah that it your instinct is good which
is let's
let me work on the thing like for
example even if you think about
oh i don't know climate right you can
start with a conservative
assuming they're somewhat saying you
would say hey listen are you are we
on the same page about like you you
really shouldn't
like put you should put your trash in a
bag and then put the bag in the dumpster
and then
that's the way to get rid of the trash
instead of driving around throwing it
out of the car window do we
do we both agree on that oh we do okay
why
and then you use that as a basis to then
get closer to a productive conversation
about
climate change and how it should be
dealt with politically the problem is
that when you make the switch from the
part of the conversation
that is just sort of like people talking
to the part
that gets recognized as the political
hot take part a wall typically goes up
so
i love the idea i love the idea i just
think it's harder to transition from the
stuff we all agree on
onto the other stuff uh but but it's
it's a very interesting idea
it's a very interesting idea okay let's
continue
with a couple more here okay
let's listen hey david
i think this whole trump stolen election
thing is complete completely
fraudulent in fact if anyone's trying to
steal the election it's him
but as a thought experiment i was
wondering
what if we found a sitting president was
fraudulently elected not
that fairly trump just anybody what do
you think would or should happen
it's so fraud it's so difficult to
answer the question
because a president being fraudulently
elected can mean so many different
things
so it's it's really hard to even take it
seriously and also
there's i don't know what people like
are
if we determine one person somehow
accessed all of the voting systems in
every state and changed the outcome
that's very different than if we
determine oh
sir you know 20 people voted illegally
in one state
it wouldn't even have changed the
results or and even if it did it
wouldn't change who got to 270. i mean
you know these these are all very
different scenarios
it's a hypothetical that doesn't even
really make um make make a ton of sense
hey david i'm a big fan of the show um i
was just curious what your thoughts were
on the copa america cup
if you're following that you know that's
a copa america cup you're saying you're
saying cup twice
that's like saying the america's cup cup
it's just
copa america i'm rooting really
powerfully for argentina
argentina winning in penalty kicks last
night
against colombia yes as in pedro from
colombia and will face brazil in the
final on saturday
the argentinian goalkeeper blocked three
of five colombian penalty kicks if you
can imagine
and i am rooting for colombia i'm sorry
i'm rooting for argentina
fry a saturday against brazil in the
final
it's time it's time for argentina to get
one okay
all right let's listen to just a couple
more of these
okay just a couple we're now down to
june 26th at 5 00 p.m
all right let's listen hi david my name
is wayne moore i live in los angeles
uh donald trump is still using this
the poem the snake which is written by
oscar brown jr in the 60s
for a record of the same title the snake
and i'm sure that oscar brown jr will be
rolling over in his grave
to know that orange [ __ ] is stealing
his music
thank you mm-hmm okay yeah no that's
good
i like that um
all right let's see what else we've got
uh
all right yeah yeah just trying to sign
up as a member here on david pakman's
show and i love it and i would love to
contact him right now but it won't let
me contact him because i'm
not addicted to twitter facebook or
anything like that
that won't give me other another way to
do it
um so i'd hate to have to cancel my
subscription
because you guys won't let me use old
school methods
um sorry
my name is joe okay and then they go on
to give their full address and phone
number
yeah listen if you're signing up because
you want to personally talk to me
unfortunately it just i would love to do
that listen
these voicemails are evidence that i
would like to have long-form
conversations with every single person
in my audience it's just exceeding the
scope of what i'm able to do there's
only 24 hours in the day
so that's one of the things that you
know i'll we'll play some voicemails
i'll read some super chats we'll take
some live calls you know all these
different things and i'll talk to as
many people as i can maybe someday we'll
do live events again
and that type of thing but unfortunately
if it's a condition of your membership
that you need to be able to talk to me
the math of it is not possible the math
of it is not possible
i i do apologize i do apologize
um oh man and this guy's pissed he's
calling back again
yeah i tried to contact for him but dave
batman got calm and he won't do it
i tell you what i just signed up for a
[ __ ] membership
so i could get on tonight yeah see this
this is sad when this happens
um i don't know how to deal with this i
don't know how to deal with this i mean
really you know
the numbers are just the numbers are
what they are
and we get three to five thousand
comments a day
across all platforms and i mean listen
we were off for a week we're only on day
two of voicemails
it's just not practical it's just not
practical and i i do feel bad about that
i apologize
i apologize um okay
let's do just a couple more
you know david i've listened to your
commentary on uh
marjorie taylor greene at the trump
rally and uh
kind of be honest with you um you know
calling her an idiot and making fun of
her anti-intellectualism you know like
fire the doctors you know
what what she has no moral
and stuff like that um
you know here's the thing about it um
you know it's very subjective
and um
it's
the thing about it it's all very true
and um it's about time
that we all really just get down to
brass
tacks and attack these people for
who and what they really are
okay you got to get closer to your phone
you just have to
you have to i've got to be able to hear
you that's uh that's that's just one of
the things if we're going to do a show i
need to be able to hear you
okay um we're really getting to the end
for today okay
let's listen to just a couple other
people
don't you think it's a little weird that
um there was a new country made that was
like german and english
and then as soon as that was made the
holocaust happened in germany
i'm sorry what was that and
um i met some of them and they're
working
running from the church of scientology
and um like adopting people
and then just like getting away with
stuff like beating them up
stuff like that anyways
i just thought that was weird that like
the correlation between
when sweden started
and just eventually the facts look it up
it's all just really
kind of uh
i guess it's circumstantial or whatever
but
no they they didn't say when sweden
started i think they said when
freedom started when freedom started
um whoa yeah we're running out of steam
on these
um i'll i could do one more by that same
caller it was the next caller
i was trying to figure out um what was
going on with mexico
they were talking about um angers and
stuff like that
and kind of like separating themselves
from
like the spanish people um
and i'm okay with the
um the mexicans here um
they're pretty much fine with all women
that have like before like this one
there's like a bad connection i don't
understand a word of it
oh and also um kovitz been happening
like for years and years before they
announced it
there was like original one called stars
and they came from back who
generally came from germany and europe
so
if anybody wants to call it like a
chinese or whatever
because it actually
evolved in europe and mutated in europe
and now it was more deadly because
before it was like
maybe uh
0.1 or something new percent of people
would die from lakovic
and now there's like this huge chance
that people are going to die from the
culvert because it mutated
in europe so if anybody wants to blame
the origins all right guys we're done
for today okay that
we're not going to be able to uh we're
not going to be able to do any more of
that
i do want to say thank you to under the
screen for signing up via twitch prime
we did the trump press conference about
suing everybody we did the assassination
of the haitian president
uh we're still getting back back caught
up to speed
um from the standpoint of the vacation
so that's going to do it for me today um
let's uh let's to play us out as i like
to say
office akimov and we'll see everybody
again
very very soon if there is anything that
needs to be
uh satirized and remixed it is trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
big massive dumps
[Music]
ducks
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
dump big massive dumpster
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once dumps
dumpsters
[Music]
what